around like a torn tendon in his foot or
plays 40 minutes in a playoff game and
he's sitting in his chair next to you
exhausted
do you think oh yeah he is 20 years in
this game uh and then does he do things
to like kind of
make that thought go away
yeah uh
I mean the fast break reverse dunk was I
was right there and I thought he was
just going to do a regular you know
Duncan and he did that and I was like
damn
you know so that was one of those
moments where it's like
all right you know it doesn't affect
them
um but then like you say same exhausted
like I don't want to say it's the 20
years you know but um he just leave it
all on the floor you know and a lot of
us are exhausted obviously I was a
little bit more miles on it than you
know all of us probably combined but
um you know we just try to do our part
around it to make you know
his job a lot easier you don't have to
over exert himself
um the entire game you know and I think
that's what happened tonight